I want to pronounce your name like the
way that your people say it I knew when
it was coming though there I know in
their minds as they were reading it they
were like thinking to themselves like oh
there's no way I'm gonna be able to
pronounce this correctly Nguyen mr. Naja
and mr. Nguyen oh look there's soybean
I've had Bianca I've had Brianna I
remember my 8th grade teacher calling me
Hamas didn't really enjoy that very much
I wish that I could have all Lunchables
at school every single day mom make me
Lunchables make me Lunchables and she'd
be like well I am NOT a corporation that
is going to feed you 3000 milligrams of
sodium here is a completely organic meal
and I would be like that is crap
I want to reduce yeah Michael Rutter
smelly ethnic food again get it out of
here no problems on that front
eight eight all the normal stuff I did
see other kind of Indian kids of Chinese
kids bring their stuff and I remember
being like that's weird
those are non-existent what is that I
don't really know what a sleepover is
sleepovers for me where basically you're
going to go over to their family's house
and sleep right everyone in their family
is going to rape you
we just didn't talk about dating in
general because that's not a thing
there's no dating you can't date you
can't date you can't date you can't date
and then one magical day when you're
getting married my mom was like embrace
your ho attune from a young age there's
like meeting people and then three days
later you're married and I mean
implicitly was no dating white girls no
dating white girls no dating white girls
no dating white girls when are you
getting married
you have a house why would you like
choose to sleep in the woods
civilization left the woods behind so
why go back camping was awesome I had an
engineer father liked we solar fried hot
dogs hello hot dogs hello
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh merci okay yeah
calling cards white kids never really
dealt with that but it was definitely
like the ultimate stocking stuffer in
our family oh okay
can you hear me hi I'll hold up it
emigrant Mexican why is that